I know you're scared
scared to start over from day one
scared that the age gap might be too big
scared that your kids might not get along
or that they won't have any shared experiences
these were all on my mind when I decided to have a third kid
my older two were 5 and 6
and we were really starting back at the baby stage from day one
and the thing that has really warmed my heart this entire time
is how seamless our third child has fit into our family
not only has our youngest grown to meet the big kids
and play with them in their own spheres
our older kids get down on his level too
so they can share these beautiful playtime experiences
honestly my oldest two are like twins
and I was really worried about upsetting that dynamic
but it is only brought them closer
and I know family dynamics
completely depend on the personalities of the kids that you get
and there is absolutely no planning for that
but I not only have had a wonderful time
watching these three siblings get to know each other and love each other
I have had a wonderful time as a parent
getting to start over from day one
because I am such a calmer
more patient
more educated parent than I was the first time around
I've been through the toddler stage
I know which typical behaviour
I don't sweat the small stuff
as much as I did the first time around
our third gets the benefit of
not just being looked after by two exhausted parents
but two doting and energetic siblings as well
can't imagine our life without our third child
because this kid is surrounded by love
he is definitely in the winter circle
and I personally love the big age gap